the terms high and low come up all the
time in Japanese pitch accent studies
but of course in reality there are much
more than just two tones speakers might
change their tone significantly based on
their emotions or intentions what
they're what they're trying to
communicate and I get a lot of questions
about this people say well I understand
that the pitch accent of the word is
supposed to be this but I'm hearing
something that's a little bit different
what's going on here now I break this
down in detail in lesson 6.3 of my
Japanese phonetic series on patreon it's
about a 20 minute lesson but there's a
seven or so minute chunk of that lesson
that I think would be very useful for a
lot of people to see so I like to share
it on YouTube today I have a couple of
comments that I'll share at the end of
the video but for now let's just get
right into it hi everyone and welcome to
episode 6.3 of Japanese phonetics by
dogen in this lesson we'll be talking
about binary graphics and spectrographs
in this series we use binary Graphics
when showing the pitch accent pattern of
a word that is to say the standard
Graphics that we use throughout this
series only show two tones high and low
this is normal practice essentially all
Japanese phonetic resources use binary
Graphics to indicate pitch accent some
do it with Graphics like this others use
Graphics like this and others still use
Graphics like this all these Graphics
are meant to display essentially only
one thing whether or not a word has an
accent and if it does where in the word
that accent occurs thus this binary
graphic for the word Japan for instance
shows me that the word has an accent on
its second Mora it does not show me how
a specific speaker has already said the
word and mapped their voice emotions and
intentions onto the word it might help
to think about things like this if I
look up the word America on
dictionary.com it gives me the
definition of the word as well as this
pronunciation key you see how the mare
section of this pronunciation key is in
bold this is meant to indicate that the
accent falls on this syllable of the
word now of course there are many
different correct ways to say America we
could say it in a happy way as in
America or we could say it in an angry
way as in America or we could say it as
a question as in America so depending on
what we're trying to say or emphasize
the pronunciation of the word as well as
the words pitch will change a little bit
however what doesn't change generally
speaking and this is particularly true
for one word phrases is the accent
location again whether it's America or
America or America the accent stays on
the Met it's sort of like the word has a
basic shape and then when we say the
word and map our emotions and intentions
onto it we sort of stretch and play with
that shape a little bit now
dictionary.com and other dictionaries
obviously can't show a spectrograph or a
computer-generated pitch wave for every
acceptable pronunciation of the word
America so instead it just shows this
again a key that shows where the accent
is the dictionary just shows the words
basic shape and then language Learners
learn this shape knowing that when a
speaker actually says the word they'll
be stretching and playing with it a
little bit binary Japanese pitch accent
Graphics are similar to this this
graphic shows me where the accent and
the word Japan is and if we had a native
speaker slowly and carefully say this
word as in
then created a spectrograph of this
recording it might look pretty similar
to this in fact let's take a look at the
spectrograph of that recording now
so pretty close right but while a
speaker could say me home
they could also say
nihong
or
or Nihon
etc etc but again it's impossible for a
pitch accent resource to list a
spectrograph for every acceptable
pronunciation of the word Japan so
instead pitch accent resources use
binary Graphics to indicate a word's
basic properties that is to say pitch
accent resources use binary Graphics to
indicate whether or not a word has an
accent and if it does where in the word
that accent occurs thus it's very
important that we Japanese Learners
realize that native speakers stretch and
play with these shapes and that because
of that what we hear won't always line
up perfectly with the kind of Graphics
that are used in this series as well as
in other pitch accent resources so this
idea that what you hear won't always
line up perfectly with the graphics that
are used in in my series and in other
pitch accent resources
oftentimes people again end up asking me
about this they say what's going on here
and hopefully now you have a better
understanding of exactly what's
happening of course there is some
individual and Regional dialects dialect
variation that can affect the the tone
and actual pitch action pattern of a
word but in my experience most of the
time when what you hear isn't lining up
with the pitch oxen pattern of the word
it's because the speaker has mapped
their emotions or intentions onto the
word they're giving the word intonation
and this in in this sense they're kind
of stretching and playing with the words
pitch accent pattern all right now back
to the video now I imagine that many of
you are now wondering two things one
exactly how do I map my emotions and
intentions onto a word and two if the
actual pitch of a word depends on how
the speaker is mapping their emotions
and intentions onto it then what's even
the point of studying pitch accent I'd
like to answer both of these questions
now first how do I map my emotions and
intentions onto a word good news you're
probably already doing this in a natural
way especially if you've been studying
Japanese for a while in my experience
Most Japanese Learners particularly
those that do a lot of immersion so
listening to Native recordings are good
at mapping their emotions and intentions
onto words they usually know how to say
words in a happy or sad or angry or
questioning way even though they've
never explicitly learned or studied how
to do this now I do give some basic tips
on this later on in the series but again
most people are naturally good at this
so if you've been studying Japanese for
a while again and you do a lot of
immersion then you're probably already
mapping your emotions and intentions
onto words in a more or less natural way
however and this is a big caveat even if
you naturally know how to stretch and
play with the shape of a word depending
on what you're trying to say if you're
stretching and playing with the wrong
shape to begin with
it's going to sound wrong that is to say
nihongo
and
nihongo
and
nihongo
are all right however
and
nihongo
and
nihongo
are all wrong in other words it's
relatively easy to map your emotions and
intentions onto a word and sound correct
if you already know that word's basic
properties and this is why we study
pitch accent we study pitch accents such
that when we're actually speaking and
mapping our emotions and intentions onto
words we're doing so with the correct
pitch accent patterns or shapes we study
using binary pitch acts and Graphics
like this
such that we can unconsciously say this
this
and this
Okay so we've learned why it's important
to study a pitch accent and also why
pitch accent resources use binary
Graphics rather than spectrographs to
teach pitch accent but is there any
useful information that we can learn
from spectrographs yes there is and for
the rest of today's lesson we'll be
talking about one of these topics so
that's a look at pitch oxen intonation
and why what you hear won't always line
up perfectly with what's on screen and
again this was a seven minute or so
sample clip from the full 20-minute
lesson which also covers a phenomenon
that I call the subtle drop in Pitch I
kind of break down what it is and how I
think that most Learners should go about
approaching it and if you'd like to
learn more about this I would encourage
you to check out the full lesson which
can be accessed here and if you'd like
to learn more about kind of the basics
of Japanese pitch accent I have a lesson
that's also available for free on
YouTube here and for anyone that wants
to go beyond just the basics I would
encourage you to check out my full
patreon series which is linked again
here and down in the description below
all right thank you for your support and
best of luck with your future Japanese
studies